hi everyone and welcome I'm really
excited to be talking to you about this
topic today because I think the decision
between using a primary or a secondary
antibody conjugate is sometimes taking
taken lightly
however if considered carefully you can
have a great impact on your results so I
hope you find it interesting and
relevant to your work and as Jessica
just mentioned mentioned at the end we
will have a tuning session in which I
will answer your questions as best as I
can so I'm just going to go ahead and
first walk you little bit through the
webinar today so first I'm going to
start by talking a little bit about the
differences between direct versus
indirect methods in and I'm also gonna
talk about the relevance to applications
such as our imaging and flow cytometry
but of course as a Google see later they
also apply to other immunoassays such as
Elijah and Western blot of course and
then we will move on and start with the
benefits and limitations of using either
a primary or a secondary antibody
antibody conjugated I take to lead to
the use of either a direct or indirect
method after that we will also talk
about the relevance of these benefits
and limitations
I'm going to talk about two multi core
analysis I know that many of you are
starting to perform multi core
experiments the propriety of using
multiple labels in your amino acids is
increasing in popularity so I thought it
would be very good to actually introduce
this topic in the webinar as well so I'm
just going to go ahead and start with
the difference between direct versus
indirect methods as you may already know
direct methods are the ones that use a
conjugated primary antibody so as you
can see here in the diagram in the
diagram in other
we have the antigen of interest in red
color and then we have our primary
antibody detect and detecting the
antigen of interest and it's the primary
antibody that is already conjugated to a
fluorophore or an enzyme or a protein so
it's actually the primary antibody
providing the signal for you to be able
to detect the localization or the
activity expression of your antigen of
interest however in indirect methods two
different antibodies are used we still
are gonna need the primary antibody
which is kind of course to the tag
guaranteed an antigen affinity of
interest but then we'll use a secondary
antibody against the primary antibody
and it's the secondary antibody which is
actually conjugated to the fluorophore
or the molecule you're gonna be able
that you're going to use as a reporter
in your immunoassay and as you can
already see by this diagram there there
are some obvious differences between the
two methods or or what is the same
between using a direct direct antibody
conjugated versus an indirect and an
indirect method or a secondary antibody
conjugated and of course these direct
and indirect methods they apply to more
similar assay so as I was just
mentioning earlier including immunity
idol chemistry or cellular imaging
immunohistochemistry flow cytometry
analyzer and I will talk a little bit
more about specifically several imaging
and flow cytometry
as i know that the popularity of these
technologies is is increasing
considerably of is increasing
considerably
nowadays so moving on on to the benefits
and limitations of either one of these
products the first one of these benefits
or limitation depending of how you look
at it is actually an obviously time so
of course and you can and this is quite
obvious a direct method or using a
primary antibody conjugated results in a
shorter protocol
the reason for that is because less
incubation steps are required tuning the
protocol so basically you have your
sample let's say and a tissue slide in
English the chemistry experiment you
incubate with your primary antibody
conjugated to HR peel let's say and then
after the intuition with the primary
antibody you are already you're you can
already use you can raise that take that
tissue slide to the master cup to be
visualized and analyzed because it's
actually the primary antibody that is
going to provide that signal after using
your detection reagent however if using
an indirect method or what is the same a
secondary antibody conjugate of course
the protocol will be longer to
incubation steps are needed first your
sample is incubated with the primary
antibody but because this one is
unconjugated the sample requires a
second a second equation with the second
antibody contributed to your molecule of
interest to users or reporter and then
at these stages when you are able to
visualize your antigen of interest so
the use of secondary antibody conjugates
results in additional steps in your
protocol so this is the first of the
factors to consider when between when
deciding between either method but of
course there are other factors as well
the second one of them is cost generally
direct sorry primary antibody conjugates
are generally more expensive not only
more expensive than secondary antibodies
but obviously more expensive than and
conjugated primary antibodies the reason
being is that of course the primary
antibody conjugated needs need to be
conjugated and that has cost to its
production
however secondary antibodies are
relatively inexpensive compared not only
of course to primary conjugates but but
also primary unconjugated antibodies and
and that of course that also adds
additional cost saving to your
experiment because you actually have
also the possibility of use
the same secondary antibody to detect
several different primary antibodies
such as we will see later we are also
going to be talking about that because
it also affects the flexibility of
accuracy so yes just very briefly
generally more expensive primary
antibody conjugates secondary while its
other and even expensive inexpensive and
you can use them to detect several
primary antibodies another factor to
consider of course is the complexity and
what I mean by complexity is actually
the difficulty of designing the
experiment and why is that because
usually indited methods result in more
complex experiments they usually require
more controls as you are having more
reagents in your experiment so for
instance of course if you're going to
have the secondary antibodies you're
going to need a control with only the
secondary antibody just to make sure
that the second antibody is not giving
you any background or false positive
signal and depending on the technique
there are also other controls that need
to be included however if using a
primary antibody conjugate
it's actually simplifies the experiment
quite quite a bit because it's already
the primary antibody is already
conjugated and they're so not so many
controls and that are required and this
of course these factors are actually
hated when doing multicolor experiments
in multicolor experiments the controls
needed in indirect methods are many more
than for direct methods and of course
you also need token for the species
cross activity and we also going to talk
a little bit about this later more in
detail but just just at the moment if we
can we can generally say that indirect
methods are more complex while direct
methods are less complex
so as I was mentioning earlier another
factor to consider to consider when
deciding between direct methods and
indirect methods or what is the same
between using a primary antibody
conjugate or a secondary antibody
country it is flexibility and of course
direct methods or primary antibody
conduit result in less flexibility why
is that because let's for instance
consider this example here we have our
three primary antibodies one against up
for another one against sucks - and
another one against Nanog it seems
obvious that in this case is an
experiment for a stem cells and of
course because we're using primary
antibody conduits or antibody conjugated
our antibody primary antibody against up
for it's already continuity to green for
for our antibody against sucks to a red
floor and then the one for nanog is
continually to a blue floor for if by
any chance we wanted to get out of this
combination this combination a series as
it is works very well the three colors
are quite far away from each other in
the dark - they respect or overlap so
it's a nice combination for multicolor
experiment but if we wanted for instance
combine our antibody against a node with
an antibody against acting let's just
say and by any change that antibody
against acting was also contributed to a
blue fluorophore
we wouldn't be able to use the two of
them in the same experiment of course
because they will be both contributed to
blue shore force and and that how using
a primary antibody conjugates limits a
little bit your flexibility in the
experiment however secondary antibody
conjugates because you can use the same
secondary antibody to detect several
different primary antibody that adds
great flexibility to your experiment in
this case for instance we have our
unconjugated antibodies primary
antibodies against up for socks - or
nanos and we have secondary antibodies
one secondary antibody is able to green
and we make it to the tech top four but
then we may have another secondary and
but we may also use it to detect nanog
of course you will need to consider the
species in which the primary body has
been raised but because usually many
different antibodies are used in a lab
you can actually have just a few
secondary antibodies that may be used
for hundreds of different primary
antibodies so are using secondary
antibodies as that flexibility to your
experiment moving on
sensitivity and and this is obviously
reflected in the diagram as I was
mentioning earlier
dereck antibody conjugates up sorry
primary antibody conjugated usually
provide a lower sensitivity and the
reason being is because it's your
primary antibody are already conjugated
so you have you don't you don't have the
signal amplification provided by the
secondary antibody when using secondary
antibodies several secondary antibodies
will bind to the same primary antibody
resulting in an amplified signal that is
not provided by primary antibody
conjugate so generally primary antibody
conjugates would result in a lower
sensitivity than using secondary
antibody conjugates or then using an
indirect method so what about species
cross reactivity so TV scholars activity
is an issue to consider when using
secondary antibody countries so if
you're using a primary key what the
country the species connectivity is
minimized your primary antibody let's
let's consider this example here we have
our antigen a and our antigen B in red
and yellow respectively and we have our
primary antibodies against at the
antigen a and Huntington antigen we
already conjugated so because we are
using a permanent device that is already
conjugated the possibility for these
antibodies to cross react with other
antigens we are interested in is
actually minimal even more if you are
using monoclonal antibodies of course
however in indirect methods that they
require the use of secondary antibody
conjugates there is a potential species
cross act
the afters of the second antibody with
another primary antibodies racing
different species so let's just consider
this example here for instance again we
have our antigen a and gem B and our
primary antibodies a and B now let's
consider that the primary antibody for
detection of antigen a has been raised
in Mouse and the primary antibody for
detection of antigen B has been raised
in rat because of the higher modes
between mouse and rat when we incubate
our sample with secondary antibodies
against against Mouse and because of
that high homology is likely that the
secondary antibody will cross react also
with the primary antibody raised in rat
here the second antibody against Mouse
is this one in blue with the green
fluorophore and you can see the one of
them is cross reacting with the primary
antibody racing rat and the same with
the plant the secondary antibodies race
against rad in this case you come you
can see in in grey conduit to up another
fluorophore and then the primary
antibody against rat is of course
detecting the primary in the primary key
value racing right but it may also
cross-react with the primary antibody
race in Mouse so there is a potential
species courses across activities you
need to account for when using secondary
antibodies however I also want to
mention that if you still need to use
secondary antibodies in your experiment
you also have the possibility of using
Prius or secondary antibody
secondary antibodies if you're not
familiar with pre absorption of second
antibodies basically this is when we get
a secondary antibody against for
instance rad and and we want to remove
all those secondaries that may
potentially cross-react with Mouse so we
get the antibody solution the secondary
antibody solution and we pass it through
a column containing serum proteins from
from
and of course a one pack when passing
through the secondary antibody solution
when passing it through this column
those antibodies and may potentially
contract with mouth they will stick to
the serum proteins from mouth containing
the column and only those antibodies
that are highly specific to detect
revive will flow through you will end up
with a highly specific secondary
antibodies so if you still need to use a
secondary antibody for your experiment
and you're worried about potential cross
reactivity you should consider using
periods or secondaries similarly another
another and the last a factor to
consider in in choosing between direct
or an indirect method is of course
background and and similarly two species
cross reactivity background as you have
probably already cast with direct or
with Anik methods or primary antibody
conjugates the background is reduce and
like like before you're using a primary
interval which is already conjugated
sort of put that the potential of this
primary antibody cross-reactive
with other antigens from the tissue and
that and then may provide bring that
that background is is again minimal
however if you're using secondary
antibodies this because you're just
adding additional reagents to your to
your experiment these secondary
antibodies may cross react with other
antigens in your tissue and in your
tissue and bring up that background even
and this is especially true and I'm very
important to factor to consider in
tissues that are highly abundant in FC
receptors FC receptors are receptors
that they interact with the constant
region of the of the prize of the
antibody and because these these tissues
that are high level in these receptors
they will interact with of course the
antibodies that we are trying to use for
detection of our a antigen appeal if you
still need to use an indirect method or
a secondary antibody country with music
and you're worried about potential
background or the interaction of
secondary devices with FC receptors you
could also use fragment antibodies and
if you're not familiar with fragment
antibodies let me just very briefly go
through it so fragment antibodies what
they are basically is as the name
implies is a fragment of the primary or
of an antibody so how we generate the
fragment abilities by enzymatic
digestion so two different enzymes are
just normally use pepsin and popping I
believe if I remember correctly it's a
pain type eye-popping which cuts here if
you can see my pointer and the popping
of course yields two different fragments
a one from in which is the constant
region and another fragment which is
what we call if FA b2 region and because
this fragment is it doesn't have the
constant region there is no concern that
email or that with FC receptors contain
in your sample I think in the guts to
pepsin I think the digestion is at this
level these Indies so three different
fragments are killed one of them is
again the FC region and then to the two
identical fragments correspond to the
variable regions and they are called a B
fragments so that again is the
possibility that you have if you're
still needs to use secondary antibodies
in your experiment so very briefly to
summarize the different factors that
need to be considered when choosing
between direct versus indirect methods
first of all time
obviously direct methods for primary
antibody conjugates result in shorter
protocols protocols
why because less incubation steps
secondary antibody conjugates longer
protocols to in Croatian steps are at
least required when using a secondary
antibody country cut the cost of primary
antibody conjugates is generally more
expensive even more than unconservative
primary antibodies
however secondary antibodies are
relatively inexpensive they're cheaper
than primary antibodies and conjugate or
con
and they can be used with many different
primary antibody so that results in
additional savings complexity as we
mentioned earlier direct methods are
less complex indirect methods are more
complex more controls require you may
need to consider species court activity
that as complex complexity to the design
of your experiment flexibility the
methods are less flexible your plot your
primary key values already conjugated
you cannot choose what label to use
because that's the mutation
however if using a secondary antibodies
the secondary antibody conjugate because
you can use it for many different
primary antibodies you can actually play
with that flexibility and choose the
color that best suits your needs or the
needs of your experiment of course
sensitivity lower for direct methods
generally higher for indirect methods
because several secondary antibody
conjugates will bind to your primary
antibody the species connectivity
minimize with direct antibodies you need
you basically do need almost do not need
to worry about the species core activity
of course there are some exceptions in
indirect methods there's the potential
of the species core activity but again
if we worried about about that and we
still need to use a secondary antibody
we can use pH or secondary antibodies
and just to mention I forgot Lu to
mention the way that you will know
whether a secondary splits off or not it
will also leave will usually be stated
on the title of the product it can be
stated as either resource or closets or
the two the two terms you mean the same
thing and usually in the datasheet the
the the species for which the secondary
antibody minimally cause as with other
stated in the datasheet in regards to
background reduce for primary antibody
countries there's no so much Polish or
background however secondary antibody
conjugates are as reagents to your
experiments or the potential background
and the potential for background is
higher with
direct method but in the end it's
actually this pretty Menten is what is
going to define the most appropriate
problem to use so you're gonna have to
consider whether you're gonna will do it
whether you're gonna introduce excuse me
sir imaging
flow cytometry or worse than blood
you're gonna have to consider these
different factors you're gonna have to
consider the abundance of your target
and and and your target of course
whether it's a membrane protein whether
whether it's a it's a nuclear antigen
all those things need to be considered
and in the end is actually that
experimental me that is going to define
we along with all these factors that is
going to define what is best word to use
a direct method or indirect method in
regards to several imaging and flow
cytometry as I was mentioning earlier so
just I think it's good that we call very
briefly through though these two methods
I'm sure that most of you are already
familiar with them and use them in a
routine basis but they have a great
impact on the decision of between a
direct method and indirect method so I
thought it would be good just very
briefly to go through them flow
cytometry samples are cells in
suspension approaching them in
suspensions of the good they can get
into the flow that the fluidic system of
the instrument and be analyzed and
measured so our imaging your samples are
going to be a hidden salts so you can
visualize them under the microscope in
regard to light detection in flow
cytometry is going to be a
photomultiplier tube that is going to
detect the signal provided by the
antibody
however in several imaging is going to
be yourself
determining what what is and what is not
a signal is the naked eye is your naked
eyes who is going to determine that the
data for signal for flow cytometry the
signal is shown as a statistical data
however no more farcical information is
provided by
so cytometry however the signal for
imaging is shown as an image and of
course with the image it comes a lot of
rich morphological information what
depending on your needs
it may be what what the experiment
requires so of course you know there are
other things like the sample is
efficient for instance in flow cytometry
is very rapid you can analyze from fifty
to four thousand cells per second
however installer imaging is
labor-intensive now there are some high
throughput screening microscopes that
allows you the analysis of off of many
samples at the same time but sterile
imaging but if you don't have access to
this type of instrument it's usually
quite labor-intensive the throughput
therefore for for cytometry is quite
high however the output for several
imaging because of this level intensity
is usually low the quantitation because
you are able to analyze so many cells
South by flow cytometry is pretty
accurate however in some limiting
imaging is limited again if you have
access to one of these high content
screening instruments for several
imaging they do of course a much better
job in regards to quantitation but
otherwise is somehow limited so if
there's a as you can see there's clear
differences in the two in the two
techniques it's not that if one is
better than the other it's just that you
may need to use one or the other
depending on on the results you're going
after or your experimental need but
basically flow cytometry some multiple
metric analysis in an objective rapid
and reproducible manner while several
imaging provides a special information
at the morphological level not only
cellular level but you're also likely to
be able to get more fogicon' information
on tissue level so and that of course
can be a great advantage but one of the
things i wanted to point out is the
general speaking flow cytometry is more
fluorescence microscopy and of course
because of that sensitivity it's it's a
great factor to consider when deciding
between using a primary antibody
conjugate or a secondary antibody turn
to it now moving on let's go very
briefly into the relevance to multicolor
analysis multicolor analysis or
multicolor experiments multiple or
experiments involving multiple multiple
labels they allow for the evaluation of
course as the name implies the
evaluation of multiple antigens within a
complex tissue and of course that can be
very helpful sometimes is you can obtain
more data with less work so who doesn't
want that
and and in but of course this has
certain these effects whether choosing a
primary contour or secondary antibody
conjugated how it affects were basically
we can say that multi color analysis
Satan's most factors in the influencing
that decision so when it comes to time
if using a secondary antibody conduits
run meant that we mentioned that in diet
methods usually result in longer
protocol so if doing a multi color
experiments the time will be even longer
of course cost because primaries develop
conduits are generally more expensive
the cost will be significantly higher if
using primary antibody countries in a
multi color experiment and secondary
antibody conduits complexity complexity
is going to be high for enlighting
methods in a multi color experiments and
again that's because as you're gonna
have to take into account more controls
here more even more because you're
playing with different colors so there
are many different combinations to take
into account and that adds considerable
complexity you also need to account for
a species core activity so all those
things are important to consider in your
experiment flexibility well it's going
to be even lower with direct
with direct method for parabolic
intuiting multicolor analysis you're
gonna be limited by programs to which or
enzymes to which your primary antibodies
are conjugated - so the flexibility is
going to be decreased even further in
multiple experiments using primary
antibody country's sensitivity well
sensitivity is probably the only factor
that is not affected by by the fact of
using of doing an experiment with a
single label or multiple labels so that
remains the same sensitivity is usually
higher when using secondary antibodies
because they're worse many of them will
bind to the primary antibodies usually
lower with primary antibody countries a
species course activity of course you're
adding even more reagents to experiments
in that in that multi-core analysis so
there's more potential for species
connectivity if you not have to use
primary antibody phrase in different
species and of course there's a chance
there's a high chance for those
secondary device to cross the act with
all those other primary antibodies
however and just to remind you here you
have the possibility of using pre and
source secondaries that will minimize
that potential cross activity background
the background of course again similarly
two species cross activity the potential
is higher in indirect methods more
reagents are add for the potential of
more interactions with nonspecific
antigens and of course resulting in
increased background so to summarize
multi-core analysis ratings more factors
influencing direct and indirect methods
so now to finalize I just want to go
very briefly through the tools and
resources that are can as a company is
able to offer you to help you in your in
your immunity use a direct or indirect
method many people
tools and resources that can be very
helpful to you so we provide highly
validated antibody countries we provide
both primary and secondary antibody
conjugates these conduits are all
manufacture or a manufacture in our labs
and to make sure that they comply with
high quality standards established by
our scientists our team of scientists
with the staff of all they all have of
course Kristi the reason they have
consider experience so that they
establish quite high quality standards
to make sure that these these reagents
perform well in your hands and to make
sure that that there are no delays in
your experiments and as part of those
high quality standards we make sure that
each of the reagents is validated in key
applications among them now we have of
course in mu no Hado chemistry like in
the example here on the right but we
also have our cytometry
immunohistochemistry authoress and
western blotting of course it would not
this will depend on the on the specific
reagent but we usually provide a
politician in in the most key
applications for the four teachers for
each reagent then all the data generated
from validation of the antibody is
provided on the data sheet the
supporting data so we provide that this
images like the one here very crisp very
specific this one specifically is for
beta tubulin conduit to Alexa for six
for seven and as you can see it's a very
very beautiful image and and each of
these images is accompanied by detailed
methods so you can reproduce it in your
lives
additionally we also have references
references from publications in which
the antibody or the region has been used
and of course we also have independent
customer review so you can see what
other colleagues from from the
scientific community think about the
performance of the product so
as part of our primary antibody
conjugated offering many of our premium
people the conduits are based on our
Rama technology and and some of you may
be already familiar with this technology
this is our unique rugged monoclonal
antibody technology it takes advantage
of the superior and P antigen
recognition of a rabbit as you know
Robby polyclonal antibodies have been
taken advantage of that superior antigen
immune system of the rabbit for many
years however it's been very hard to
develop monogrammed device in rabbit
there were certain limitations that we
managed to overcome a few years ago and
we developed this fantastic
Ramnath technology that allow us to
develop monoclonal antibodies in rabbits
so we take advantage on one side of the
superior and attained recognition of the
rabbit and at the same time we provide
that that increased specificity and
consistency of a monoclonal antibody and
we have combined these technology with
alexa fluor dyes and as you know this
these dyes have become really popular
they much more common fluorescent dyes
here's traditionally such a speedy
psychiatry a right-wing or ABC and in
many cases alexa fluor dyes are brighter
than the conventional dyes they also
show a greater stability so they allow
you to excuse me they allows you for
longer image capital times and the
pitching sensitivity is also brought
over it's also it's also boot over a
broad pitch range and of course they
also have a good water solubility so
these are are very consistent eyes that
perform really well and and and of
course that many of you have probably
already use so we have combined both
technologies of Rama pan technology with
alexa fluor dyes to bring to bring you
an exclusive range of conjugated imap
primary antibody so this range is
exclusive to up come with chosen the
targets based of course on
scientific demand based on on the needs
of your experiments and and the range is
growing considerably with I believe we
have already more than 1500 primary
antibody rom map primary antibody
conjugates on our catalog and we're
gonna publish many more in the coming
year in the coming months as I mentioned
our Romick technology means high
affinity because of that superiority of
the rabbits immune system and of course
it's a monoclonal antibody the elec
supplies provides both and bright images
for the right signals and as I just
mention it's a fast growing product so
each of these from a primary antibody
conjugates is accompanied by beautiful
beautiful images showing its quality in
this case we have arrived in Munich
Renault - hm-hm gb1 it's it's a looker
antigen and you can see a very bright
nuclear signal here and we also provide
you an example of how it works in
multicolor experiments in this case we
have acting I believe in red color and
of course we're using Dappy to label the
nucleus and then we're making all of
them to show you the performance of the
antibody in a multicolor setting so
which product datasheet contains this
high quality imaginary not only for our
imaging but for flora comes in many
cases as well and the methodology is
detailed for each one of the images so
you can reproduce the data in your own
lives so very briefly countries Rama
Brahman antibodies Rama Manta valleys
the benefits of course are a higher
bountiful affinity and a specificity for
a good signal amplification alexa fluor
dyes right this diet on the market we
also add an additional separation step
to remove any unbound by the results
from the conjugation of the antibody so
this ensures a high signal-to-noise
ratio many of the antibodies have been
validated for both immunization
chemistry
and flow cytometry so we being bring you
confidence and trust in the performance
of Afghan tbody and we have them
installed across the different offices
that we have around the wall so you can
make sure you receive it in a timely
manner so as I mentioned earlier we also
have quite a broad range of secondary
antibodies conjugated to Alex offshore
dyes as I was just telling in the
earlier these are manufactured in-house
complying with high QC standards
conservation we make sure the optimal
number of fluorescent molecules per
antibodies achieve and purification we
have that additional step to remove tree
lines resulting from the conjugation to
ensure the high sensitivity
we've also optimize the formulation for
optimal performance and shelf life and
they're extensively validated each of
our secondary devices contribute alexa
fluor dyes in flow cytometry in you know
Sara Sidle chemistry and fluoresce in
Western blot difficult and all these
days is provided on the data sheets with
extensive product information and and
veto authority to bring bringing you
trust and credibility on the performance
and up of the product on our a range of
Alec Alexa for secondaries is ideal for
multicolor experience analysis we
currently offer secondary antibodies
conjugated to different to nine
different alexa fluor dyes that cover
the whole expect room with minimal
specter overlap and they can be used
with most common lasers also the of
course this broad range of second eyes
is meant to target a diverse set of
species and the right subtypes to make
sure that you find the antibody the
secondary antibody that you need some of
them has been raised in different
species including donkey coat and rabbit
so you can play with these depending on
underneath for your multi color
experiment and a large selection of
these antibodies are pre observe so you
don't have to worry about the species
course activity in those multi color or
multiple labeling extra
but in case we don't we unfortunately
don't have your primary antibody of
interest already conjugated we also
offer a large range of antibody
conservation kids they allow you to
easily add the label you need to your
antibody in a quickly manner for hours a
standard however we also have some fast
conservation kids that allows you to do
it in less than twenty minutes which is
quite convenient very very fast labeling
of your antibody they as I mentioned it
can be do easily is simple protocol and
constant time is actually only 30
seconds and the important of course
think here is is the antibody recovery
which is a hundred percent with our
antibody conservation kids and you can
just from 10 may grams to two milligrams
or antibody being injured conjugation so
you can make sure that you don't lose
any amount of your primary antibody
during the process and our range
includes a large diversity of resin dye
such as peat see cyanides we also have
die light dies all types are all
different types of dyes but we also some
fluorescent proteins protein such as
micro ice cream and also some tandem
dyes which are sometimes very useful for
flow cytometry such as percy p & cy 5.5
in regard to resources we have a thermal
imaging guide it contains a lot of tips
on protocol for your servant imaging
experiments and then there are also of
course on products highlighted there and
that we believe we lighting it will add
significant value to your experiments
and shooting performance and and
optimization won't be required as much
with these type of products of course
the the 2008 primary and secondary
device on some kids all relevant to some
imaging and we also have a very nice
program
chart is a comprehensive height to
Kirkham to forum selection so in the
forum chart you will find the steps to
fall to make sure you select the
appropriate antibody for the appropriate
program for your experiment with a
selected 30 of the most popular programs
and we provide a mission and excitation
expect lasers filters and brightness for
this for this program so please go to
our website i've come to come and check
it out because both resources are great
useful so thank you very much for your
attention and and well we'll go ahead
with the Q&A session so hand it over to
Jessica so so we can go have with your
questions thank you
so we have a few questions here so let's
see the first question is can
conservation of the primary antibody
affect each performance so that's that's
a good point yes it can affect of course
contribution of the primary antibody can
affect in some cases the performance of
of the antibody and however for our line
of Rama antibody consciousness as I've
mentioned earlier we validate each one
of them in different applications they
comply each one of them with high QC
standards established by our team of
scientists so we make sure that you
don't have to worry about that that
problem with the potential problem with
performance of the antibody when
contributed to two different different
molecules so you can be certain that if
using one of our ramped up until you can
do it you won't have to worry about the
performance if having to rely on an
antibody contribution kit normally these
are these our contribution kids they're
they have been designed so at the
conjugation is gone to the groups that
are less likely to affect the
performance of the antibody so there's
there's a very low probability of the
performance off of the conjugation of
the antibody affecting each
if it's performance if using one of our
conservation kids I hope that answers
your question
this is a second question here which
reads is it possible to use primary
antibodies raised in the same species in
multicolor experiments alright so yeah I
think of course this is a problem that
many people come across and so of course
my first recommendation is tight try to
stay away from of course using primary
antibodies raised in the same species in
a multicolor experiment if having to use
secondary antibodies of course so first
there is the consideration if you're
using an antibody a primary antibody
conjugate it really doesn't matter the
species in which the antibody has been
raised in the dark to come in there are
two species connectivity because it's
already conjugated so so that less
progress for you if you're using an T a
primary antibody country however if you
need to use a secondary antibody that's
something you need to account for and
and if you need to use a secondary
device then what I would recommend the
first and foremost is is using permanent
eval is raised in different species
however if it's if you think you need to
use a primary antibody or primary
antibodies rate in the same species you
might be able to use them as long as
they're
isotypes are different so for instance
let's say and and even more if they are
subclass different so for instance let's
say that one of your primary antibodies
is the isotype of your first primary
antibodies is a ITT 2a and then the ISO
Tecate of another primary antibody is
igg3 we have a secondary device that is
specifically detect ITT 3 or ATT 2a and
they do not detect other subclasses or
all right so types and so and you may be
able to use those secondary device to
detect
both primary antibodies in a multi Lukic
multiple labeling experiment but but you
can already see it's quite limited
your your your possibilities that you
have also the possibility of using
biotinylated secondaries and using
fragment secondaries to get away with it
there certain combinations that you can
do so so yeah you can definitely explore
disclose those if you've really needed
okay so let's go ahead with another with
another question so we have a third
question how can I know whether my
secondary antibody is pH oh sorry so so
yeah as I was mentioning and you're
doing the webinar so pre absorption is
usually stated in the name in the
product name so you will have for
instance go to enter rabbit IDT HTML
election or a pre adsorb so if you find
pho for or across observe both terms are
just it reduced to mean the same thing
that means that the antibody has been
petrified you want to know the species
that against the antibody has been
cleared short - you have to go into the
datasheet there normally stated there we
have another question what should we
consider while selecting perforce so
that that's a very good question and I
recommend you to go to overthrow Rock'em
chart the product program chart provides
a guide of the of the the step that you
need to follow when selecting a program
but very briefly first thing the first
thing of course is the abundance of your
antigen oh sorry I should I should say
the first thing is your instrument so
the reason men will define what programs
you can or you can not use there that
depending on the lasers and the filters
that are equipped in your instrument you
may be able to use some one or other
photo force and and power program chart
is equipped with common lasers and
common filter
to help you know what fluorophores are
available to you so once once you know
that then you have to consider of course
two things one one side you have to
consider the abundance of your antigen
and why is that the reason being is that
there are some four that are brighter
than others so of course if you are only
looking at one antigen and you're using
one antibody of course I would recommend
using going for for alexa fluor for a
eight or feet see because most
instrument if not all are equipped with
a blue laser for detection of that
fluorophore
and because it's a very bright floor for
however if you need to look at several
antigens then you will need to consider
the expression of the antigen because
you're gonna want to use the brighter
floor for with your hydrogen express
express in lower abundance and and of
course your your less bright fluorophore
with the highly expressed antigen let's
say that you want to look at the acting
and on ki67 so k67 it is only a few
cells we express ki-67 and but all the
cells with we express acting and in high
amounts and and you want to use for
instance i don't know let's say i think
i could of course a good combination
would be for aid and and maybe six or
seven so or let's say maybe more drastic
up four or five four or five and six or
seven or six six or seven is definitely
brighter than four or five so you would
want to use six or seven for the less
abundant target in this case k67 not
four or five for the higher abundant
taxi i thinking in this case acting so i
got a couple of more questions in here
so i have primarily why with isotype IgG
two but unable to find second antibody
having i
the tool then in this case which
secondary device should we consider so
in this case you can consider the
secondary antibody that these men to
detect the heavy and light chains of ITT
in general so that's the most common
secondary and you can go and use any for
instance a goat and the rabbit IgG hnl
so usually secondary is detecting the
heavy on light chains are usually and
obviously that the problem usually
states H and L which of course stands
for heavy and light chains and it will
detect ICT to to ICT to because the the
different IDT subclasses they share the
light chains so the difference between
these I so diapers of classes is
actually the heavy chain what remains
the same is the light chain and because
you're going to use a polyclonal
antibodies secondary antibody detecting
both the having light chains you cannot
be able to detect your primary antibody
with ICT to isotype we have another
question can I use primary and secondary
antibody conjugates in the same
experiment yes you can use them but of
course if juicing and primary antibody
conjugated I will try to stick to
primary antibody conjugates because
basically if you're using if you if you
combine them
you're basically missing or not on most
of the benefits of using a primary
antibody country which is a shorter
protocol time and lower complexity
complexity you don't have to worry about
the species cross activity or background
so yes you can use them but I would say
I would certainly recommend not to if
possible because then this is just kind
of missing the benefits of a primary
antibody conjugates so we have another
question how does criminality of the
antibody affect the different factors
that are that we went through so
so yes how dramatic the effects so
that's that's a very important of course
factor to consider criminality whether
that be the antibody is monoclonal or
chronic or polyclonal has of course
impact on whether choosing a primary
antibody conjugate or a secondary buddy
conjugate basically a particular
antibody will of course react with many
different epitopes of the the antigen or
if it's secondary antibodies a primary
antibody if using a monoclonal antibody
only one epitope will be recognized in
either the antigen or the primary
antibody and and of course you know if
you have an antibody that reacts that
reacts with different epitopes you are
not going to end up with several
antibodies reacting with either the
applicant or the primary antibody
resulting in in an additional and
increased signal amplification so i I
should mention that there are some
secondary devices that are monoclonal
antibodies and of course these secondary
intervals will only read with an epitope
in the primary antibody and that signal
amplification that I mentioned earlier
of resulting from the interaction of
several second antibodies with the
primary antibody won't happen if using a
monoclonal second antibody so that's
that's a good point you should
definitely consider the project
criminally the chronology of your
antibody so yes I think I think we don't
have any more questions again thank you
very much for your attention
it was my pressure talk about this topic
and I'll hand it over back to Jessica
thank you thank you everyone